regen kommt starkregen sogar vor zwei
wochen hätten wir vielleicht noch
gejammert und gesagt acht was für ein
sommer aber seit vergangener woche ist
eben nichts mehr so wie es mal war und
deswegen schauen die menschen in den
hochwassergebieten voller sorge zum
himmel und fragen sich was da kommt wir
können jetzt schon sagen es wird nicht
so schlimm an unwetter das vergangene
woche sich dort abgespielt hat aber es
kommt eben regen beziehungsweise
starkregen wieder hinzu und das macht
natürlich einen unterschied wenn man
kein dach über dem kopf hat oder wände
aus dem haus gerissen wurden oder wenn
kanalisationen nicht funktionieren und
deswegen werden wir gleich dorthin
schalten und hören wie die menschen sich
auf das vorbereiten und auch was die
feuerwehr zu ihren einsätzen sagt und
wie sie sich auf dieses wochenende
vorbereitet
eure meinung ist gefragt könnt ihr immer
hier teilnehmen im chat oder an diese
jetzt eingeblendete adresse auch fragen
stellen an zdf heute - live at zdf.de
zunächst wollen wir hören was genau auf
uns zukommt und wir haben ein gast hier
bei uns aus der zdf redaktion bis zum
teil schön dass du da wie halo ist das
einfach erstmal weil das ist glaube ich
die wichtigste frage der zeit was kommt
auf uns zu
also zunächst einmal müssen wir
verstehen dass dieses tief anders ist
als tief bernd letzte woche das war ja
ein tief was quasi über deutschland
hängen geblieben ist und sich ganz
langsam bewegt hat und teilweise
eigentlich gar nicht aus deutschland
heraus bewegt hat erst einmal und
permanent diese feuchte luft aus dem
süden angesaugt und dadurch kam es zu
diesen lang anhaltenden regenfällen
was wir jetzt haben das ist ein anderes
tief das zieht am ärmelkanal mit seinem
zentrum entlang sagt auch subtropische
luftmassen an und die ist eben warm und
feucht und da entwickeln sich
hauptsächlich gewitter denn es ist eine
kaltfront die diese gewitter auslösen
wird und der unterschied ist dieses teil
das schwenkt durch quasi es dauert
übrigens auch länger als normal sage ich
mal
es ist schon ein langsam ziehen das tief
aber keines was quasi stationär rumliegt
und sich gar nicht mehr bewegt was er
wirklich unüblich ist das war ja letzte
woche das entscheidende dass so viel
wasser über so einen langen zeitraum
entsprechend sich da ergossen hat genau
das eben zu diesem hochwasser führten
aber irgendwie ich vorhin schon sagte
wenn man jetzt buchstäblich kein
nach über dem kopf hat und eben jetzt
starkregen hinzu kommt auf welche mengen
muss man sich da vorbereitet was sagen
eure hochrechnungen
ja es sind 30 40 liter möglich das
problem ist mit diesen mit diesen
angaben
es kommt eben darauf an wo sich das
gewitter bilden also wenn das gewitter
erst einmal können wir nicht sagen wo
sich einzelne gewitterzellen bilden das
ist tatsächlich nur kurz vorher möglich
aber nicht ein tag vorher und das ist
eben das problem mehr zu sagen da und da
bildet sich jetzt ein tief und da kommen
die großen regenmengen
das ist nicht möglich aber wir können
die region eingrenzen und das ist eben
der südwesten deutschlands also das
zieht wie so ein band zieht es quasi
richtung mitte deutschland von
frankreich über und das alter die region
in nordrhein westfalen da genau da sind
durchaus da sind durchaus auch gewitter
und auch starkregen ereignisse möglich
ja aber lokal und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass im süden mehr runterkommt ist
größer als im westen in diesen
betroffenen gebieten
aber es ist nicht auszuschließen also es
ist sehr verzwickt wenn man jetzt quasi
gerade in so einer situation gewitter
relativ orts genau vorhersagen müsste
aber es ist von der metrologie her
schwierig gehen wir gleich noch mal
genauer darauf einen aber jetzt erst mal
du sagst es ist langsam wie lange wird
sich das tief über diesen regionen
halten über das also über diesen
regionen wird es sich nicht so lange
halten also es sind bänder die
durchziehen und dann dreht sich das tief
ich mach das mal mit den händen
es dreht sich dann raus nach norden und
das ist dann etwa am montag und dienstag
aber nach nach dahinter her kommen
weitere regenwolken sage ich mal
und also es ist erst mal der bange blick
aufs wochenende
das ist auf jeden fall ein gewitter ist
es ja dabei also in der nähe von den
gewittern sind orkan bis zu also wie
sagen wir mal die höchsten
geschwindigkeiten an
nimmt man das abschätzen kann ist eine
orkanartige böen möglich vor allem aber
dann auch wieder im süden deutschlands
sturmböen kann ich nicht ausschließen
wenn ein gewitter auch im westen über
das land zieht macht natürlich auch ein
unterschied ob ein haus intakt ist so
ist es oder eben schwer beschädigt
wir sprechen gleich weiter erst mal sehr
gerne für den moment öffnen und schauen
auch heute vor ort und dort ist auch
heute marion geiger und zugeschaltet und
kann mich jetzt hoffentlich hören hallo
marion sehen und hören sich genau und
vor allem hören wir dass hinter dir
kräftig gearbeitet
du bist immer neuenahr ahrweiler ja was
wird da gerade gemacht wird der
aufräumarbeiten sind im gange ja hier im
aartal bereiten sich die menschen eben
auf diese staaten regenfälle vor
und das sieht man hier hinter mir jetzt
im moment sehr gut es wird jetzt mit
hochdruck daran gearbeitet das die
brücken der die eingestürzt sind letzte
woche dass die nun beseitigt werden
bevor die a wieder mehr wasser führt
hintergrund ist dass sonst befürchtet
wird dass über treibgut und ähnliche
dinge sich eine art barriere bildet und
die könnte dann brechen und wieder zu
kleinen sturzfluten führen also da wird
jetzt verstärkt daran gearbeitet hier
diese brücke hinter mir die wurde mitten
in der nacht angefangen abzubrechen
haben wir anwohnerinnen und anwohner
berichtet dass sie aufgewacht sind kurz
vor mitternacht von diesem lärm und die
hatten sich erst ganz schön erschrocken
und das nicht nur diese brücke die
abgerissen wird sondern auch eine brücke
weiter vorne
damit eben diese gefährlichen engstellen
im fluss vor den regenfällen beseitigt
werden können
daran arbeitet der krisenstab ja die
zeit drängt ganze gehört bei uns jetzt
sozusagen dann am morgigen tag losgeht
aber was sagen denn die menschen mit dem
du sprichst einerseits sind die wände
noch nass das dach nicht dicht und jetzt
geht's wieder los
ja also die die bandbreite der
reaktionen auf die frage wie sie jetzt
auf den regen morgen schauen ist
wirklich sehr groß ich habe einmal
getroffen der sagte was morgen gibt es
regen
das weiß ich noch gar nicht habe gerade
sieben tage lang sieben tage lang mein
keller freigeschaufelt über fische den
schlamm rausgeholt
andere blicken durchaus mit sorge darauf
natürlich die einen versuchen sich
rational zu sagen es ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass sowas nochmal
passiert wir hoffen ganz einfach dass
kein starkregen zelle direkt über uns
ist und andere sind sehr beunruhigt und
weise zb auch darauf hin dass bei ihnen
die kanalisation noch verstopft ist und
schon jetzt ständig das grundwasser
weiter in den keller drückt und die
haben natürlich sorge dass es morgen
wenn die art meerwasser für verträge
kommen
oberflächenwasser nicht abfließen kann
und bald wieder in den keller läuft
wir wollen es ja wirklich nicht
herbeirufen aber wenn natürlich jetzt
wieder wasser kommt wenn man das hört
wenn man sich sozusagen wieder auf eine
ausnahme situation vorbereiten muss
spüren sie auch ängste dass das so was
wieder hervorruft dass der letzte woche
ja noch gar nicht verarbeitet werden
konnte auf jeden fall also ich habe mit
einem jungen mann und seinem vater
gesprochen die waren gerade dabei hier
ahrweiler zu verlassen
der junge mann hat letzte woche dieses
hochwasser miterlebt und der sagt er es
so dass er jetzt raus kommt weil er
diesen regen eigentlich nicht miterleben
will also es hat auch der vater gesagt
dass er gar sorge hat dass allein durch
dieses geräusch des regens oder auch das
geräusch der dass da einfach alles noch
mal was die leute einen schrecklichen
letzte woche erlebt
haben also diese ängste sind auf jeden
fall da es gibt aber auch das muss ich
auch sagen leute die sozusagen mit einer
art galgenhumor sagen ach so ein
bisschen regen ist schon ganz gut weil
was hier im moment sehr sehr kraft ist
es ist die staubbelastung in der stadt
also wir sehen heute an den
wasserstraßen wo wir jetzt nicht mehr
stehen können damit wir keine wege
blockieren aber an den straßen die am
schlimmsten betroffen sind
da ist ein unglaubliches
staubbelastungen die leute sitzen jetzt
mit rp zwei masten vor ihren häusern
weil sie diese nicht weiß ist kaum fragt
man können unsere stadt ist der staub
und da sagen dann eben auch viele wir
hoffen dass der regen uns mit dieser
staubbelastung hilft also insofern ist
es ein ganz gemischtes bild die einen
gucken nur relativ gelassen entgegen
einfach auch weil sie hier mit aufräumen
beschäftigt sind und die anderen die
haben eben sorge und sind heilfroh dass
sie hier rauskommen was man schon mal
die infrastruktur angesprochen drücken
haben im hintergrund gesehen aber jetzt
um auch damit umzugehen
wie ist denn momentan die situation wie
sieht's aus mit wasser trinkwasser strom
elektrizität telefon meine ich ja also
strom gibt es meines wissens nach noch
nicht die leute behelfen sich mit
stromaggregaten in den häusern
es gibt seit gestern abend hier in
diesem stadtteil von ahrweiler wieder
wasser das ist natürlich kein
trinkwasser abwasser aber immerhin
können die leute sich wieder in den
häusern mit wasser versorgen
das dann abgebrochen und
benutzen auch um sauber zu machen denn
es wird dringend davor gewarnt das
wasser der aa zu benutzen
meine kamera frau mira kann euch das
vielleicht mal zeigen
die ady sitzt die läuft im moment so
ganz ruhig fließt sie dahin
und man kann die uferbereiche schon
wieder sehr gut gehen und wir sind viele
leute die hier zum beispiel eimer
auswaschen oder staaten abwaschen oder
sich auch selbst abwaschen und davor
wird dringend gewarnt weil in diesem
wasser einfach sehr viel heizöl ist ja
wie kalium und hilfsstoffe die durch die
ganze zerstörung ausgeschwemmt werden
aber auch ungeklärte abwässer bei der
kanalisationen zerstört sind und es wird
auch davor bewahren dass hier noch viele
tierkadaver leben dieses wasser
verseuchten
da rechnen die bürgermeister hier an der
a4 in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler damit dass
es eventuell zu einer rattenplage kommen
könnte also die situation ist nach wie
vor schwierig obwohl es kleine
verbesserungen gibt telefon gibt es noch
nicht fest wird das mobilfunk netz
funktioniert so einigermaßen stabil
inzwischen wieder
es gibt vom land rheinland pfalz
aktuelle informationen demnach werden
noch immer 149 personen vermisst was ja
auch einfach eine gigantische zahl ist
ein betrag der opfer die man schon hat
das von 149 menschen immer noch keine
spur ist wenn da jetzt geräumt wird man
muss ja auch immer damit rechnen dass
man irgendwo noch tatsächlich auf
verstößt ideen die rettungskräfte damit
um oder was heißt das für eine stadt
dass es da immer noch so viele
fragezeichen gibt
ja das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen also
gestern wurde hier in der nähe zum
beispiel eine person leider tot aus dem
keller geworden die anwohnerinnen und
anwohner hier rechnen damit dass da
weitere tote gefunden werden gerade
jetzt wenn die keller langsam abgepumpt
werden
das ist natürlich eine große belastung
wieder haben einfach auch gesehen wie
menschen in autos mitgerissen worden
sind und wissen zum teil auch nicht wo
leute sind die sie eben kennen und
insofern ist es natürlich super wichtig
dass man diese menschen findet damit es
da gewissheit gibt aber natürlich ist es
auch eine riesenbelastung für vor allem
für die rettungskräfte
es besteht halt leider auch sehr sehr
wenig hoffnung
menschen die vom wasser mitgerissen
worden sind noch lebend zu finden also
die rettungskräfte die rechnen schon
damit dass sie dann nur noch tote werden
können maria und ich komme zur letzten
frage danke erstmal bisher aber billig
bleibt noch eine beide weil ich wollte
hier nur mal schnell schauen was
sozusagen in den kommentaren kommt vor
allem alles positive meldung vom mit
führende meldungen jeder ebene heißen
dass man hofft dass es den menschen gut
geht und dass hier auch das gut
überstehen einer fragt uwe sannwald ob
die evakuierung schon mittlerweile
begonnen hat und die menschen sich in
sicherheit bringen konnten nur damit wir
das noch mal richtig einordnen also
momentan sieht dass ihr alles total
friedlich aus da hinter dir und wir
haben sie auch hingehört es kommt regen
das können unwetter kommen auch
orkanartige böen aber auch fast treffen
sie denn da genau gehen die menschen
tatsächlich eher weg oder oder hält man
das aus und ist auch genügend hilfskraft
da um zu sagen wir wir können das hier
stimmen also ich hab jetzt niemanden
getroffen der mir gesagt hat dass er
jetzt aufgrund der erwarteten regenfälle
und unwetter das haus verlässt
es ist allerdings auch schon dazu zu
sagen dass sehr viele schon weg sind
also gerade ältere menschen wurden
einfach weg gebracht zu verwandten und
freunden oder auch in not
unterkünfte damit sie aus diesen
zerstörten häusern raus gekommen sind
und viele leben halt noch im ersten
stock dort harren sie aus und die werden
jetzt auch die häuser nicht verlassen
wenn es zu diesen regenfällen kommt das
ist hängt auch damit zusammen dass sie
angst haben dass geplündert wird also es
geht hier auch ganz viele geschichten um
das da eben leute unterwegs sind die
sich noch bereichern wollen in diesem
elend und insofern also ich habe
niemanden getroffen der gesagt hat wir
wir flüchten jetzt wir fliehen
ich habe einen jungen mann getroffen von
dem ich vorhin erzählt habe der gesagt
hat er ist froh dass herr aus ist aber
jetzt niemandem der aus abends vor dem
unwetter wirklich hier das haus noch
verlässt von den leuten die ohnehin noch
hier sind mario
vielen dank für diese informationen live
aus bad neuenahr ahrweiler für diese
eindrücke und schilderung dankeschön und
via skype bin ich jetzt verbunden mit
frank hammer dass der präsident des
landesfeuerwehrverbandes rheinland pfalz
schönen tag nach koblenz
wir haben jetzt gerade gehört sozusagen
direkt im bericht vor ort sie haben den
überblick darüber was die feuerwehren im
land in rheinland-pfalz leisten was ist
die größte sorge momentan wenn der
starkregen kommt ja wir betrachten das
aus sicht des landesfeuerwehrverbandes
jahr hauptsächlich als beobachter auf
dem hintergrund und wir haben ja einige
informationen inzwischen aus der
einsatzleitung durch die idee auch schon
in der öffentlichkeit erhalten
die größte sorge ist natürlich wie gehen
wir um mit möglicherweise betroffenen
gebieten wir haben ja ebenso stehen rtl
ii wenn sie einfach geschrieben bekommen
dass er zum glück nicht mit einer lage
rechnen müssen wie das in der
vergangenen woche war das heißt also
dass ich nicht mit dauerregen oder so
etwas zum glück aber wir haben punktuell
durchaus die gefahr dass der veganen
starkregen bekommen werden das ist ja
durchaus möglich und es wäre ja auch
sollten am besten da die augen zu
verschließen
wir haben vorhin ja schon gehört es wird
jetzt kampf nicht krampfhaft jetzt sehr
intensiv sein muss und will ich sagen
darum sich besorgt
dass die brücken zum beispiel leer
geräumt werden das überhaupt große teile
aus deraa beispielsweise ausgeräumt
werden warum ist das so wichtig genau es
gibt also an zielen der hindernisse die
also sowieso schon dadurch bestehen dass
wir im strom stehen also ehemalige
brücken die leider teilweise eingestürzt
sind und anderes mehr gibt es das
problem dass ich möglicherweise dass es
dann auch mal unangenehm aufstauen
könnte und dann selber außen weitere
überschwemmungen möglicherweise
verursachen könnte da will man den
durchschnittlichen aber das hauptproblem
was die einsatzkräfte offensichtlich
sehen ist nicht dass die aa noch mal
großartig über die ufer treten könnte
sondern sie haben mehr das
oberflächenwasser vor augen also
punktuell sa die im gesamten gebiet
überall das gleiche problem aber da wo
er stark rücken herunter kommen könnte
dann gehört das sind nicht die mengen
die wir in der vergangenen woche hatten
der reden jetzt nicht mehr von 200
litern pro quadratmeter einen langen
zeitraum sondern überhaupt
dies ist also nicht und also deutlich
unter 50 wo ebenfalls litern pro
quadratmeter das aber daneben punktuell
das ja aber zum glück nur sehr kurz und
vergleich zu vorher aber das eben ist
das große problem dass wir hier gucken
müssen was passiert mit diesem wasser
die kanäle sind alle noch zerstört
weiterhin oder hat eben auch verstopft
und anderes mehr das heißt der abschluss
ist nicht ohne weiteres gewährt
liegt das nur an der zerstörten
infrastruktur dass die kanalisation
dieses wasser gar nicht aufnehmen kann
weil es gibt gar keine kanalisation mehr
oder hat es auch tatsächlich mit der
beschaffenheit der oberfläche zu tun wie
es momentan aussieht genau also da kann
sich ja einiges zusammen natürlich
einmal ist die infrastruktur natürlich
stark angeschlagen nicht zu sagen in
weiten teilen zerstört und dann haben
wir dann selbstverständlich auch selbst
in sachen verschlossen oberflächen das
ja vielfach der boden durch den arten
schlamm auch schon versiegelt ist an
manchen stellen
das alles führt dazu dass man sich
sorgen machen muss wie gehen wir damit
um
er hat mir sicherheit er nicht mehr mit
überschwemmungen zu tun haben die in dem
ausmaß wie wir das erlebt haben in der
vergangenen woche leider das nicht aber
es kann halt eine anderer stelle so sein
dass man darüber nachdenken muss auch
wenn die menschen tatsächlich verlassen
kann
da reden wir uns nicht von der gesamten
bevölkerung oder so aber wir reden dort
einzustellen
wo wir genau hinschauen müssen dafür hat
man auch vom vorgebracht es gibt also
möglichkeiten auch dann in dem falle
menschen obdach zu bieten sozusagen da
werden bereiche aufgebaut
neben meinen bringen kann wo sie dann
trocken sind
und sicher und sie seien busse zu
stellen wie das auch dann leisten können
und um das richtig einzuordnen als wir
reden nicht davon dass hier großflächig
evakuieren sondern da wo etwas passieren
kann oder wo sich die lage wieder
zuspitzen kann sind sie vorbereitet um
die menschen raus zu bringen und in
notunterkünfte beispielsweise zu bringen
habe ich sie richtig verstanden
das ist im moment der aktuelle stand
dass man sich darauf vorbereitet hat man
hat ein expertenteam zusammengestellt
dass ich genau mit diesen fragen befasst
hat und zunächst einmal diese schritte
einleiten wollte und das auch gemacht
hat und man betrachtet natürlich sehr
aktuell jetzt die genaue entwicklung was
wird jetzt vorkommen was denn passiert
ändert sich etwas und dann sehen wir
darauf selbstverständlich auch
entsprechend sehen wie steht es denn um
die infrastruktur der zeit wir haben
vorhin schon gehört strom ist schwierig
telefonieren geht manchmal aber was was
es sozusagen das was sie bisher
erreichen konnten oder wo gibt es noch
schwachstellen
na ja also das mitbekommen ist
tatsächlich dass das mit dem handy
empfang schwierig ist nach wie vor hier
und da also sie da immer noch in
schwierigkeiten stecken das hinzukriegen
da scheint sich aber tatsächlich langsam
zu verbessern immerhin was die
zuwegungen angeht zu den orten scheint
es so zu sein dass aktuell kein ort mehr
nicht erreichbar ist das haben wir wohl
hinbekommen
und es sind inzwischen auch wohl an
allen punkten im tal zumindest
anlaufstellen oder auch reste von
verschiedenen hilfsorganisationen
vorhanden
die direkt vor ort einschreiten können
wenn irgendwelche schwierigkeiten aber
besonders aus laufenburg
wie gehen sie denn auch die menschen zu
also von warnungen war in den letzten
tagen häufiger die rede was da gemacht
wird gemacht werden kann oder wie man
diese warnungen auch kommuniziert wie
sieht es da momentan aus ja da ist
natürlich klar dass durch die zerstörte
struktur dort jetzt nicht schnell
irgendwelche serien ausgebaut werden
konnten zumindest keine festen sondern
wenn wir jetzt natürlich dazu übergehen
dass die bevölkerung her gewarnt werden
kann
gerade auch in der kronen stark das wäre
jetzt und da wenn man also
offensichtlich mit lautsprecherwagen
arbeiten
das ist auch ein probates und bewährtes
mittel das kann wenn das gut organisiert
ist ohne weiteres gut funktionieren auch
für feuerwehrleute ist es ja natürlich
eine belastung wir haben für einen
beispiele gehört es werden immer noch
opfer gefunden man muss wirklich mit den
menschen in dieser notsituation 24
stunden umgehen das macht ja auch was
mit ein
selbst welche rückmeldungen haben sie da
ja das ist natürlich ein thema sind
alles auch nur menschen muss er wissen
die meisten sind ehrenamtliche die
unterwegs sind gerade bei den
feuerwehren auch mit den anderen
organisationen weitgehend daher haben
wir das geht nicht die kräfte die von
einiges natürlich auch erlebt haben weil
sie vom länger aktiv sind und andere
dinge mehr aber viele haben auch gesagt
auch langfristig also der leute die
lange im feuerwehrdienst sind bereit so
etwas habe ich noch nicht erlebt
es geht mir selber auch so ich bin seit
36 jahren im feuerwehrdienst nach so
etwas tatsächlich noch nicht sehen das
lässt alles nicht kalt das ist ganz klar
die einen kommen damit sehr gut zurecht
ich war gespannt wie sich das für viele
auch in den nächsten wochen entwickeln
wird wir hoffen dass es allen gut geht
wir haben aber natürlich auch essen zum
glück und sie haben auch zum glück
solche kräfte wir haben die
unterstützung aus ganz deutschland
zurück bekommen auch bis heute schon und
das wird er sich auch so weitergehen
natürlich dass wir das richtig kräfte
bekommen können die dafür sorgen dass
die örtlichen kräfte von hier aus der
näheren umgebung die auch viele tage im
einsatz waren auch mal raus gelöst
werden können marie kreieren können
sozusagen sich etwas erholen können und
einfach wieder zur verfügung stehen auch
sie ihren eigenen branche zu hause oder
auch eben im aartal und das hat
natürlich die ausgelösten gäste dann all
dem einfach mal raus können und neue bei
jetzt also wir haben also 720 kräfte aus
schleswig holstein im einsatz
wir haben 600 gäste aus bayern wir haben
aus vielen anderen bundesländern dass
die hier im einsatz gehabt also das ist
eine ganz große bereitschaft den
feuerwehrangehörigen am ende auch sicher
nicht sehr gut tut keine frage hier von
markus via youtube er fragt ob die
feuerwehr eigentlich momentan noch damit
beschäftigt wie zum beispiel sandsäcke
in dieser region zu bringen ist das noch
ein thema ist das gehört dazu oder ist
das an schutzmaßnahmen was möglich ist
gemacht
also alles was da an akutem bedarf
austauschen sollte wird mit den kräften
die im moment shorts in bewusst
abgewickelt das machen sie die ganz
direkt ganz viel ist für den samstag
lager wir sehen wie im tal auch hier und
da bestehen der band also palettenweise
sandsäcke dahin geliefert das ist
sicherlich nicht überall so aber da wo
das noch gebraucht wird kann man das bei
den örtlichen kräften auch artikulieren
und dann wird er sehr schnell dass wir
gesagt dass wir kommen
das ist ja inzwischen da übrigens eine
konzertierte aktion das ist ja nicht so
dass da nur feuerwerk gäste sind da ist
das technische hilfswerk sehr aktiv
inzwischen auch schon die ganze zeit
eigentlich aber jetzt noch mal ganz was
dies auch mit in die verstärkung
eingegangen
wir haben die bundeswehr wir haben die
weiße schiene anführungszeichen also
alle rettungsdienst tätig sind und das
ist eine sehr gute zusammenarbeit
zwischen denen sich ganz toll entwickelt
hat ich sage deshalb inzwischen dass ein
stand von anfang an natürlich so aber
jetzt ist es eben auch noch mal eine
konzertierte aktion die ganz bewusst und
zielführend zusammengeführt ist
ordentlich glaube da müssen wir uns erst
mal keine sorgen machen dass da nichts
funktioniert das heißt sehr sehr gut und
alle sind sehr sehr engagiert bei der
sache
wir wollen das gerne essen ja das sieht
man auch tatsächlich mehr den bildern
die ganzen rückmeldung sieht man wie
groß die hilfsbereitschaft da ist in
jeder hinsicht auch als das
spendenaufkommen betrifft da kommen aber
gleich noch zu abschließend noch zu
ihnen
jetzt kommt regen und auch starkregen
mit orkanböen das sicher schlimm aber
man muss sich natürlich auch damit
bewusst sein
das wird ja dauerhaft kommen es kommt
eine herbst es kommt ein nächster winter
auf was richten sie sich denn ein wie
lang sie da vor ort sein und bleiben
müssen und sozusagen auch dieser alarm
bereitschaft bereitstellen müssen ja
genau die feuerwehr ist ja jetzt
speziell betrachtet eine organisation
die normalerweise in ihrer dna hat dass
sie jetzt alarmiert wird und sofort
hilfe und jetzt ist sie natürlich in
großer anzahl dort im tal eingesetzt
sozusagen der katastrophenschutz lage
kann man sagen das heißt also da sind
auch lange wartezeiten da und all das
dies ist eine zeitspanne die wir jetzt
im moment gerade beginnen wo es geht der
feuerwehrkräfte auch noch einfach mit
anpacken um keller leerzupumpen anderem
er klavier zu räumen und anderes das
wird wohl sicherlich noch etliche tage
wenn ich wirklich weise sogar wochen
andauern müssen da bereiten sich alle
darauf vor dass solche kräfte
herangeführt und anderes mehr
und dann irgendwann wird der zeitpunkt
kommen natürlich wo die feuerwehren vor
allem dazu da sind um den grundschutz in
anführungszeichen sicher zu stellen aber
einfach dafür zu sorgen was ist jetzt in
wiederbeginn den alltag auch da wenn wir
hier und da notfälle leider erleben
müssen und das wissen die feuerwehr dann
auch wieder da haben sie ein überblick
sonders ist ist man was ist eine
realistische einschätzung
also da sagen die experten
unterschiedliche von mehreren tagen ist
über wochen habe ich davon alles gehört
das müssen nur situativ schauen weil
natürlich auch insgesamt nicht in jedem
einzelfall klar ist wie lange dauert das
ist ja auch sehr gleichzeitig was da
abläuft sind teilweise es hätte da wo
man sagen muss dass angerichtet als an
ein anderes fälle wo sie zum glück auf
wenn das das richtige licht am ende des
tunnels ist das ja eben auch in der
reportage hintergrund gesehen dass der
ausbauarbeiten sehr lästig im gange sind
das macht die sache natürlich an der
stelle super aber an anderen punkten ist
es halt eben noch ein bisschen anders
dann muss man mehr gemacht werden
deswegen sind dass vorhersagen und
prognosen sehr schwierig franka vielen
dank für diese information und für diese
einordnung aus koblenz dankeschön erst
dann abschließend noch mal werden sie
gehört wie gesagt es kommt wetter es
kommt unwetter mit starkregen und auch
orkanböen
das ist das eine aber auch abschließend
an dich noch mal die frage nach diesem
dramatischen erfahrungen jetzt in der
vergangenen woche das hat ja alle
sensibilisiert nicht nur die anwohner
sondern eben auch die rettungskräfte
aber auch die wetterredaktion ist das
thema bei euch dass ihr euch überlegt
was lernen wir daraus
ja auf jeden fall ist wurde viel
diskutiert und wir haben das analysiert
wie wurde berichtet was haben mir
berichtet
und ja also es wurde viel berichtet es
kann mir auch verschiedene vorwürfe auf
aber letztendlich ist das eher so dass
wir als meteorologen nicht mehr machen
können als die zusammenhänge zu erklären
darauf hinzuweisen die wettervorhersage
zu machen
es wurde ja sogar von uns verlangt dass
man warnung so ausspricht dass die leute
quasi ihre häuser verlassen
das ist aber nicht unsere aufgabe das
müssen katastrophendienst dann vor ort
leisten oder andere behörden
wenn wir im fernsehen sagen würden ihr
müsst morgen eben müsst eure häuser
verlassen
das ist denn das können wir nicht
leisten weil wir die information vor ort
nicht haben und das können eben nur
behörden vor ort tatsächlich klären ich
wollte nur noch sagen diese orkanartigen
böen die sind eher im süden deutschlands
also im westen sieht es eher nicht so
einfach so heftigen unwetter wie im
süden aus also das ist jetzt nur eine
relativierung ich will nicht sagen dass
dort nichts passiert oder dass die
gewitter nicht stark werden und über
kein starkregen kommt es ist eben ein
wenig weniger als im süden
dass man das nur ein bisschen einordnet
weil wir aber noch bei dem punkt dass
diese katastrophe natürlich
aufgearbeitet werden muss und es geht ja
nicht um schuldzuweisungen weder in die
eine noch in die andere richtung sondern
eben dass man sich vor
was lernen wir daraus waren die
warnungen eindringlich genug man muss ja
auch jemanden höhe finden der darauf
hört das ist mir sogar eine warnung ja
auch tatsächlich ankommt und ich glaube
ganz wichtig ist auch man muss ja auch
erstmal verstehen von welchen
dimensionen wir da jetzt reden unwetter
kennen die menschen und waren das
gewohnt aber plötzlich in dieser
größenordnung das ist ja auch
buchstäblich neuland oder oder habt ihr
so was vergleichbares schon mal gar naja
gut also es ist zwar neuland in dem
sinne dass ja die wetter- extreme immer
stärker werden im zuge der veränderung
unseres klimas wir wir leben ja mitten
in der klimakrise sage ich immer denn
das ist ja nicht das kann man nicht
ausschließen auch wenn verschiedene
kräfte da sind wir wieder probieren
auch die diskussion in eine andere
richtung zu drehen es sind es sind
zusammenhänge mit der klimakrise die
sind relativ eindeutig und diese diese
art von von unwetter
damit werden wir in zukunft leben müssen
und wir hatten vor einigen jahren jahren
beispiel auch im gebirge starkregen und
dann floss das wasser den weg des
geringsten widerstandes das war ja ein
braunsbach zum beispiel auch ein
katastrophal wir kennen die bilder
vielleicht noch wir haben sie noch im
kopf und so ein ähnliches ereignis was
letztendlich also wir können jetzt nicht
davon ausgehen dass das nächste ereignis
erst in zehn jahren wieder auftaucht wir
müssen damit rechnen dass es vorher
passiert und dass es so ähnlich sein
wird denn wir leben ja trotzdem in
tälern in der nähe von flüssen also wir
müssen uns grundsätzlich auf etwas
einstellen was in den nächsten jahren
zunehmen wird und das wird ja auch nicht
in den nächsten zehn jahren auf das wird
in den nächsten 20 jahren sich
fortsetzen
wir leben in der klimakrise und das
wirkt immer stärker da rein und das kann
man nicht außen vor lassen und das wort
jahrhundertflut macht an der stelle auch
keine werbung kein wenn man gar nicht
mehr so weit voraus sehen kann dass es
einen anderen regionen ab trifft aber
insofern sind wir bei den punkt wie
genau könnt ihr denn eigentlich
vorhersagen was gesagt dass du ihr habt
rechenmodelle und man sieht da kommt ein
tief man kann eben nicht genau sagen wo
sich jetzt das gewitter genau entlang
was sind denn so
ich sag mal den kilometern oder einen
reichweiten etwas wo er sein konto
das können wir sagen und das können wir
nicht sagen also das modell macht mir
schon relativ genau genau bereiche wo es
quasi regnet wird
aber es ist nun mal auch so dass wenn
gewitter sich bilden kann es sein dass
es fünf kilometer weiter im osten
passiert und dann ist es genau da wo wir
dann gesagt haben dass es da schütten
wird nicht passiert wie soll man das
rechtfertigen also was man machen kann
ist eine region festlegen man sagt im
südwesten deutschlands von der
schwäbischen alb bis zum weinen zum
beispiel das ist hier zb eines der autos
der modelle werden morgen große
regenmengen erwartet weil dieses tief
eben das kommt von frankreich rüber und
schiebt die kaltfront rüber und da
entwickeln sich eben entlang der
kaltfront dieser heftigen gewitter du
siehst ich versuche physikalisch darauf
zu antworten und versuche das soweit
einzuordnen aber diese einzelne gewitter
was den massiven regen an einem ort
bringt und vielleicht dann zur
überflutung führt kann ich dir nicht
vorhersagen
zumindest nicht von heutiger sicht aber
morgen wenn du dann auf den radar guckst
und da möchte ich wirklich alle
auffordern die morgen auch in den
katastrophengebieten sind einfach mal
aufs wetter radar zu gucken zu sehen
auch das kommt und sagt das noch wenn
das wetter so zu sagen ja also wenn wenn
ich sehe wie das gewitter aufzieht da
ist ja eine zeit eingeblendet also ich
sehe wie die zeit sich verändert dann
kann nicht abschätzen dass es vielleicht
noch eine halbe stunde dauert dann muss
man natürlich auch ein bisschen gucken
löst es sich auf verschwindet es
plötzlich und baut da etwas neues an
wird es intensiver geht es in rötliche
farbe und dann zieht es weiter ich
versuche jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
diese dieses radar auch zu erklären wie
man das quasi interpretieren müsst auch
das gehört dazu dass man sozusagen
gewarnt ist das könnt ihr machen aber
genauso sich selbst dann auch zu in form
halten
ich würde sagen wenn also jetzt ganz
grundsätzlich wir als metro logan würden
sagen wenn wir am abend zuvor sagen es
ist morgen eine unwetterlage dann sollte
man alarmiert seien nicht in dem sinne
von alarmismus wie manchmal leute dann
dann sagen ach ja regen hat es früher
schon immer gegeben es war auch immer
schon heiß und es hat auch schon immer
sehr viel geschneit in den 80ern das
sind im moment einfach ernst nehmen ist
es eine unwetter lag
und dann einfach morgens aufstehen um
mal zu gucken was zeigt denn der
deutsche wetterdienst der ja die
amtlichen warnungen verkündet sind da
vorab warnungen das sind diese
gestreiften bereiche und in diesen
gestreiften bereichen kann es zu
unfällen kommen und dann auch nur den
text lesen was steht denn da drin und
einfach eine eine quasi eine resilienz
dafür entwickeln wie man mit unwetter
umgeht ich glaube einfach dass auch die
erfahrung über viele jahre dass wir sehr
weit entkoppelt sind von von natürlichen
veränderungen phänomenen und wetter ist
eines der phänomene oder beziehungsweise
eines der begebenheiten die ja permanent
um uns herum ist es denn wie ernst wird
das nehmen müssen ist jedem klar
geworden spätestens in der letzten woche
danke erst in sehr gerne und auch danke
ihnen für die spendenbereitschaft denn
es kommen enorme summen zusammen und wir
wollen gerne die tafel noch mal zeigen
und sie bitten wenn sie möchten hier zu
spenden ein aufruf vom aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser
deutschland nachlesen können sie das
auch wenn sie noch mal in ruhe schauen
wollen unter spenden punkt zdf.de und
dem zdftext seite 890 ja danke für ihr
interesse
wir hoffen natürlich dass es nicht so
schlimm kommt aber es gehört zur
wahrheit dazu man muss sich darauf
einstellen und es gibt viele die alles
dafür tun dass es nicht so schlimm wird
in diesem sinne danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und bis bald
[Musik]